another what if episode today i'm
excited for this one party though
guys if you end up enjoying our reaction
please go ahead and hit the like button
or the dislike button doesn't matter
which one it all counts also subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction for what
if is up as always you said it's a
gazillion times i'm going to say it
again full length watch alongs where you
sync it with a time coder over at our
patreon page the same tier we have
reaction highlights and watch alongs for
many a show lastly thank you to berthom
jindal or jaden not sure which one of
you is editing this but appreciate the
work and the effort buddies
let's do this
[Music]
darcy
good job
my bingo card
it's started it's doing the beeping
i need to talk to the director of shield
because if my data is corrected believe
an alien invasion is imminent and hello
tisk tisk your dull lives are about to
come to an end
prepare yourself for the party
parents
instead of raising the jutenheim prince
loki as his own son odin returned him to
his people without his trickster brother
to keep things lively thor grew into a
very different prince
a clean shaven one
he's asleep
and uh i'm off to my sisters to
celebrate the solstice
[Laughter]
read up on the nine realms that you will
one day rule of course mother no parties
of course mother remember heimdall will
be watching
wait what i can't be serious behave
oh be high baby
this he's literally getting left home
alone for the first time
but your mother said don't be such a wet
blanket guys stop my father has ruled
asgard for centuries and look at the
most interesting thing
looks like i got all the stones too
[Music]
welcome
friends yeah
hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm gonna make first contact with an
alien first i think half the strip you
do it you can make first contact with i
don't know that guy he looks like a
loser
big talk coming from that
[Music]
you guys really get me yes
huh oh
oh
there you are all the way down there so
tiny i almost stood on you
[Laughter]
oh
what do i always say i love cake that is
this voice thor
as in thor the norse god of thunder i
don't know anything about horse gods but
i don't know how to bring the thunder oh
god nice do all geniuses have such deep
dark eyes it's like watching the birth
of two stars in the edge of the galaxy
oh
half-price nachos okay fine duck but
this is not a date let's just see where
this evolves
it's a grandmaster
definitely yeah it looks like his hands
oh just homies there too
[Applause]
[Music]
valkyrie
[Laughter]
oh hell yeah dr james foster
vegas baby
rocket
nice little uh john favreau shout out
you were the first to warn us about this
extraterrestrial threat now i hope you
will be the key to eliminating it
eliminating it
hey
this might be your party but this isn't
your planet before someone gets hurt
oh no
do you have company dr foster uh a
friend guys guys look there's a cute
little rabbit in the sink
this is earth's first encounter with
alien life you're wrong doctor this
isn't shield's first alien rodeo
[Laughter]
it's done all right here we go
yes
he's here
oi
where's that son of the witch
no way
in full frost giant form
[Music]
i can't believe you can't
wait what's that boom
did you boom no i didn't boom did you
boom you always boo i never
boom in private oh we gotta become the
frost giant cake sorry
it's okay i wish i wish
wait some party you're throwing isn't it
the best i mean i'd hoped the ice bros
would show but loki himself prince loki
are you kidding i wouldn't miss this for
the world
prince loki
you know there's a mid-guardian word for
women like you
[Music]
party pooper
there i said it
[Laughter]
wow
now for the rest of you oh
awesome still worthy
falcon punch
[Laughter]
oh but i just
have to do a little boop
what have you done
this bowling pin sound
no your weird rocks have all fallen over
oh she really cares about those rocks
stein
america
all the use of the map
oh
wow cool
that was cool
[Laughter]
they're gonna like destroy earth i think
that's where we're headed
they're going around the world fighting
be careful guys
titans
[Applause]
if i exert my full powers i blow a
crater in this planet taking down kappa
kappa frat freak won't be worth the
fatalities ooh what about south dakota
or north dakota
darcy right now you're running at an
eight and i need you to take it down to
a four okay
at your last party on alpha star did you
really destroy that planet no no it was
more of a meteor anyway not a planet and
it was burning apart so we just kind of
helped it along and so no one got hurt
no of course not
dr foster i gotta go love you
nice she's thunderstruck
look who came waddling back mrs the duck
uh not now howard
put him on the phone oh don't get your
knickers in a twist he's right
oh right hello loki
oh
hey hey
watch the feathers too bad we can't call
his mom
you really are a genius it's really
starting to look that way isn't it
what'd i say
oh no
you know i've got a crown oh no
oh sir
[Laughter]
they are destroying the planet
oh
watch me slide down that pointy thing
back home
[Laughter]
i really like this episode
it's a blast
[Music]
whoa
you figured it out
super easy
[Music]
no
about thor's
we're in position arm the nukes what but
i thought she was the nuke just in case
she gets distracted by a cat damn real
you played dirty yeah
cut throat
uh
chardonnay a varietal yes can i help you
it's thor
he's in trouble
three
he's on earth
two
what about captain marvel she'll be fine
[Laughter]
crown prince of asgard mother mother
mother i'm obviously in my room studying
she smiled me and my uh study group came
down here for a cultural exchange
cultural exchange
i'm cutting my trip
coming here and my sweet son i expect to
see your full syllabus
stand down we're done here
we never get to fire the nukes
[Laughter]
we're about to make this universe's
greatest slingshot
no more swing shots no more destruction
we need to clean this mess up and go
home
oh god
is that fear
it looks good it looks like uh
oh what was his name sean gunn too
party's over you don't have to go home
but you can't stay
wait where are you going come back no no
no no no yeah like everyone from
guardians
look who's pooping the party now it is
you you are pooping the party where
[Laughter]
[Music]
you will listen to me
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
take it or solo yeah seriously the pie
frogs
[Music]
i mean you could have left those
though
welcome to our study group
everyone say hello to mother
mother you doubt
here's the information you requested on
human civilizations and i loaded a few
documentaries pbs specials npr podcasts
thank you for helping educate my son
let's go daddy
almost forgot
oh
[Laughter]
jane foster it would be my honor to take
you on a date
uh before you answer let me say that i
know a whole planet full of unicorns
even the waiters the unicorns it's
wonderful
pick me up at eight the watchers smoke
in a joint
then i wish that party never stopped
as children both human and asgardians
say together they lived happily ever
after wait what
huh
oh dear oh perhaps i spoke to them
[Music]
oh my god that was cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn
where's that what if episode of ultron
season two jesus was that episode
what if ultron one
got all the stones i actually used a
vision skin
cool i thought that was fun that was a
blast that was a lot of fun hundo p
and i'll be honest i kind of enjoyed uh
pre larson here significantly more than
i did in your own solo movie
marvel outing yet
definitely building some goodwill
[Music]
greg
has a correction to make instantly
is that uh it was not pretty larson
after all it was alexandra daniels who i
believe voiced captain marvel earlier in
this
is the rest of the video just me doing
that absolutely
that's the way to go uh yeah make a
screen saver like a 10 hour loop of that
yeah yeah anyway yeah i thought that was
a really fun episode i was pleasantly um
pleasantly surprised by how well
executed that was it was like uh it was
like a a teen throwing a high school
party
sort of movie with a lesson
about responsibility which is
essentially what thor has to learn in
the first movie too because it has that
romantic comedy element
frigga's like the parents are coming
home crap we got to clean up this party
before the parents come home you know
it's the exact world's gonna kill me
yeah it's a high school party movie yeah
but just wrapped up in
the marvel format that's managed to
surprise me with some
cool like this this is going to have
like a gazillion easter eggs for people
who are doing breakdowns especially like
i can't wait for new rock stars uh
presumably eric voss to point out all of
the characters are in here because i'm
they got to opponent like i'm just gonna
it's gonna be like space jam new legacy
i'm just gonna start paying attention to
the background or not what's going on so
i just need to focus right now because
i'm sure there's like gazillion
characters and i just flew over my head
way more convincing party action than
space jam a new legacy yeah but i like
how we still had to learn responsibility
and i love how
it had this angle to it where
sure thor is more irresponsible but
weirdly he has a better relationship
with his with loki than he ever has you
know it took him a long time to get
there it was all the way up to like thor
ragnarok by the time he had a a good
relationship with loki and even then it
was still a little they had such a
history of strain there but here it's
like now they get along really well
pretty much
the whole cosmic side of the universe
for the most part with all these
characters
they're all getting along so it's
actually not a terrible thing yeah yeah
like
the the decision to put loki back with
the frost giants you know seems to have
worked out pretty healthy for everyone
some ironic touches to it yeah um but it
had this really good rhythm and pace and
it knew exactly what kind of genre this
episode was supposed to be and then it
featured like really cool action with
captain marvel and thor like the the
action was awesome that's those are
elements of that that were of course
teased in you know that that one little
exchange in uh at the beginning of
avengers end game of oh man it'd be cool
to see them fight and then here you you
get the fight scene and it was enjoyable
and it's like chris hemsworth getting a
chance to double down on the comedy
again
i liked it i liked it quite a bit it was
really fun it was wacky wild and uh just
had a great time yeah absolutely no no
like gripes about like oh i wish this
thing got more time or this thing got to
breathe more and i think too after the
past
couple past handfuls have been pretty
bleak uh yeah to get one that is
fun in a way that feels exactly
proportionate to the story they're
telling i think was quite nice and yeah
this was like the perfect length and
everything was like the perfect height
and i think too because the previous
episodes have gone to some pretty heavy
places uh it kind of helps that it sets
you up to be kind of looking out for
like oh man when's this major turnaround
gonna come and i thought they they
slayed the stage nicely for that end
moment because that is like the worst
possible reversal you could imagine yeah
then they do tease that with the glove
in the background with all the infinity
stones
so yeah ultron does get to become
you know ultron
fully realized has the stones thanos
doesn't have to step in and go fine i'll
do it myself
his vision underneath it was cool man i
thought this was just a really cool
episode and
honestly there are qualities to it that
i kind of enjoyed a little bit more here
than i did in some of the movies there
was i thought though the romantic angle
with uh jane foster
and thor
had a little bit more charm for me than
in the actual movie and i liked the
first movie a lot i i enjoy that movie a
lot but to me in that first one it was
like they have good chemistry but it is
like two hot people that they're putting
together and here
i felt some of the charm and i i like
just how uh teenager-esque it was with
their romantic part of it you know like
she's all she blushes a lot and gets
insecure about some things she's
actually says i love you on the phone
you know i love having those qualities
yeah absolutely and i mean you know it's
nice to have i was a little
back and forth just it's a pet peeve of
mine when anyone's like on the phone
with someone they shouldn't be on the
phone with while the people they
shouldn't be on the phone in front of
her like literally over shoulder uh so
like there were
like i thought that they they made that
romance it's funny like in the movie
it's not my favorite aspect of that
movie or at least it's not the part that
sizzles the most out of that movie and
yeah i think you're right though here
they did bring it a very humorous and
very uh yeah youthful charm that i
ultimately wound up appreciating despite
that nitpick that is just my own this
almost felt akin to like what they did
with lego batman yeah you know yeah
especially with the end when
everything's just going crazy yeah
search or messing around and stuff like
that yeah yeah and it seems like you
know especially as we crest into the
last couple episodes of the season you
know we go towards the end we know
things are gonna get you know heavy i
thought yeah this this felt like a party
beyond the actual plot of the party yeah
so yeah it's like when they are
destroying stuff it still feels like a
pretty fun party and then yeah you do
have this bad at like really badass
fight between the two of them and two
like this was an episode where
i
in a different way like this there were
elements that almost reminded me of like
pixar concept art when they're doing the
whole map bit and they're like you know
punching thor into you know the the
american midwest desert you know or
they're you know in the in the uh you
know snowy mountains like there was just
such like a nice
tour of earth that we got to go on tour
of midgard well i felt like this was the
one episode that really embraced that it
was a cartoon absolutely yeah that's a
great way to put that it's not at odds
whatsoever with that it's perfectly
harmonized with being a cartoon yeah i
thought it was so funny
and like even you know getting the sides
of frigga were was a refreshing quality
uh i think my one issue with this
episode
is
the majority of darcy did not land for
me
that's the one part it was like joke
joke joke joke joke joke with darcy to
the point where it even reached a point
for me
of
this is even seeming a bit out of
character
you take some of this a little seriously
because you're still a science person
yeah especially because you know maybe
from just going off of the first thor
if i had only seen her in the first
horror movie it's because we got to hang
out with her in one division yes she got
to become a much more of a fleshed out
character
you know maybe not like fully but she's
more than just a funny science lady yeah
but here it was just like
none of it felt like a scientist
co-partner it was all just
and i thought most of her jokes were
kind of a little flat for me it's that
comedy dynamic that that i think does
happen a lot in cartoons where the joke
character almost seems to exist outside
of and beyond the scene for us to react
to and nobody else in the scene to
usually react to so it's like very much
it's for the audience it's a joke and i
think that if anything and i didn't i
wasn't like that i wasn't bugged by it
but i do agree like not a whole i could
tell in those moments you're going for a
joke and it's hit or miss as to whether
that will land for me yeah they were
they were spotty and i feel like that is
maybe an element of
of the issue to be had with marvel humor
is you know
the the marvel humor i think people
complain about the most is when it's
like oh yes a joke and it's not really
for anything in the scene but it's for
us to laugh at yeah you know well
especially because everything already is
a joke in this episode there's that too
yeah like if this was a serious episode
she was the comic relief it might be yes
there's no need for her to be a relief
because i'm like this whole episode is
comedic darcy unchained at this point
yeah like yeah we're having a party just
throw out any clip you want like half of
me was like i bet they just let her go
in the studio and they just you know
threw in a bunch yeah i got like i like
the whole thing with her marrying like
howard the duck and all that like yeah
that was really funny
yeah yeah and i was still happy to have
like her her presence there yeah yeah
let's see here yeah it looks like most
people returned mm-hmm yeah looking at
this yeah majority obviously not rene
russo she had bigger fish to fry and
even got karen gillan and back for
a couple lines here nice to hear kobe
smolders
and it was cool getting this uh dark i
mean i'm sure you're you're like more
than halfway through agents of shield
yeah i'm in the second to last season
yeah so you're like pretty familiar with
what they do with shield in the movies
at least you know other than when you
find out that there's really hydra
they they uh
i like the um the tough decision making
that you get to see here where they're
willing to sacrifice people you think
about like
brock rumlow that was a surprise i was
like he got a genuinely funny moment
here yeah hey man someday he'll get his
nukes he will
uh yeah uh it's funny how this keeps
ending on dark cliffhangers
amazing cliffhangers what if these are
how does how do they call how does the
multiverse collide here it was like
zombie thanos versus ultron with the
infinity gauntlet yeah yeah and then
captain carter and
supreme strange will have to team up to
take on them and then yeah evil ultron
maximum and all that every episode of
season two will just be the cliffhangers
at the end of season one i thought this
was very enjoyable very inventive i love
that it braced and embraced that it was
a cartoon
um there's a difference it's like i i
felt like with the take the doctor
strange episode for example that really
embraces the animated medium and and
there's a kind of a different slant to
it when you say it embraces a cartoon
feels a little more loony and fun yeah
but guys what do you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button
and hey we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]
and we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]